all right can everyone hear me okay yeah
one two three yeah I think everyone
um your question is if you can actually
get a copy of this notebook right yeah
yeah you go on the SK time GitHub
okay
let's just raise your hand and to help
out inside yep sure sure no problem all
right hey uh good good afternoon
everyone uh thank you for being here
um so my name is Jonathan I've worked
with France to help develop SK time
which is what your SK bass was born out
of so what I'm going to talk about
France kind of gave you a high level
overview of some of the general methods
and interfaces that are built into
sklearn and then also SK time and so you
sort of saw the end result of what they
are just curious who here has actually
used uh SK learner SK time before
okay at least a few of you
um so if you've used it I mean most if
you if you work with machine learning in
Python most people recognize it as
probably
the most popular tool that you typically
use you know to basically interact with
ML
um
if you if you haven't used it uh
something you should probably know if
you actually want to build an ml toolbox
probably the easiest way to get other
people to use it is to make it as SK
learn like as possible because that's
basically what everyone's already used
to using and so if you want to
dramatically reduce the amount of
developer overhead require like the
brain cells required to get yourself
introduced into like a new framework
it's almost imperative that people
almost need to use it exactly like
sklearn
um
and so France talked about right some of
the the higher level interfaces they're
just kind of built into the library
so what I'm going to talk about is if
you actually want to spin up your own ml
code base what some of these usage
patterns actually look like if you want
to implement them with SK Bass
all right so let's go ahead walk through
this
so what we're going to use as an example
um I'll point out this is meant to be a
bit on the the simplistic side okay just
to make sure it's didactically clear
we're going to go ahead and Implement a
base class for permutations and then
we're going to make separate instances
of that that Do bubble sorts and then
also do data shuffling okay right again
this is not meant to be to represent The
Cutting Edge of machine learning is to
provide a very very simple and clear
example so that way the usage patterns
we're talking about will be clear
because we don't actually have to want
you to think about what's going inside
inside the fit method
Okay so
you could perhaps point out how some of
the examples we're giving are a little
bit toyish but that is actually the
point just to make sure we can focus on
the most important details
all right let's take a look at some code
okay so it is if you install SK Bass
you can import something called the base
objects this in a lot of ways is
probably the bottom of of the SK based
code pyramid if you will so what we're
going to do
we're going to create
an empty classier called base Bermuda
all right
this is really just an abstract high
level class
one detail you want to bring your
attention towards
France previously talked about the tag
system which is sort of a way to
organize broader sets of details you
know between different classes across
your code base you can see it
implemented right over here
all right and then fit here is left
empty
and then what we're doing
all right we're creating a bubble sort
class up here
okay notice here we're also defining the
tags this one if you notice is slightly
different so the value for always sorts
completely is set from false to true you
might actually just want to pay
attention to that because we're going to
use that to highlight some of the
details of SK Bass
all right we're initializing it here
with the Constructor method
all right so if it's a sort function you
know you can make something ascending or
descending
and then finally here
I don't know if if any of you are
planning on applying for a new job and
you want to pass the data structures now
goes portions in the beginning you know
maybe you want to pay attention to this
if not you can probably just ignore it
you know because you're probably not
gonna have to implement a bubble sort
from scratch anytime soon
all right so the idea then all right so
here's the the underlying logic of it
and then you return the array
all right so
if
seeing is believing this will actually
go ahead and then sort the array for you
all right so the idea then
uh this is fairly simplistic uh we have
one method fit and then it inherits from
the base object so when you inherit from
base objects
all right
um if you've used SK learned before I
mentioned frond mentioned this right you
basically modify the parameters of an
algorithm using good parameter set
params and so this is basically already
installed already uh one two inherit
from base object and so you can see over
here all right if you want to modify the
parameters for a class it's basically
already built into the base object
itself
all right uh Franz also mentioned the
tag system
which I will get to a little bit later
here
okay
and the next detail we're going to talk
about here right uh is the shuffler
class
okay and again this is a bit of a simple
example this is something that will take
an input data and then just randomize
the order for it okay uh something you
might want to draw your attention to
just in terms of how you know SK bass
works and some of its underlying details
um let's go ahead let's go back up
forward
all right so in bubble sort we are
explicitly defining the tags right over
here
all right I'm sorry in the base class
over here
we're also setting them right over here
like this all right but in the shuffler
class down here
okay uh they're not being determined at
all all right so the idea is uh the tag
system inside SK bass is based upon
inheritance so if we look through this
okay uh the tag system
basically automatically inherits from
the base class which is the base
permutation class
whereas the tag system uh for the bubble
sort
use the ones that are user specified
over here like this
all right one detail I might want to
point out is in base sklearn there's not
really a tag system but when SK time was
built
oh I'm so sorry okay
not something I use regularly I
apologize
okay okay thank you
but I think with around 1.0 it must have
been
yeah yeah so thank you if I was
operating on incorrect information I
apologize I you probably used to use an
older version of sklearn which doesn't
have this so thank you for the
correction appreciate it
yeah yeah
I understand how about this we'll we'll
restrict our conversation the way I know
it's true
um when we've actually sort of built
things into SK time the use of the tax
system has actually been very very
helpful for creating useful abstractions
that will kind of apply across the code
base so that I feel confident about
the other parts uh we'll just kind of
let that drift and then we can Circle
back to it later on to determine uh its
exact level of Truth
all right so the second thing we'll talk
about here
all right is uh basically defining
configuration variables for a particular
class
all right so the idea is uh tags
basically exist for developer
functionality because it can allow you
to Define uh basically how different
types of classes can be used at a very
high level and then also it's helpful
for user functionality because users can
use this to quickly sort your search
your code base to figure out what parts
the code base fit a certain criteria
you know so in the case of SK time
you know if you want um you know if you
want to search for a particular
algorithm which basically only works
with a particular sort of data input
that's maybe you know nested or
three-dimensional you can sort of find
out that information relatively quickly
okay
uh configuration variables uh they're
defined in a similar way however their
use case is primarily for the end user
okay and then the idea behind the
configuration variable is it's actually
used to determine a particular classes
Behavior yeah you might address this
going forward yeah
interior tags
so that your your class becomes
searchable
no I
yeah yeah it's built in SK Bass
yeah yeah one thing I'll point out so
I'm just kind of giving a brief high
level overview and then uh in the third
part of this this tutorial Franz has
kind of going to a more involved example
that'll kind of like kind of work with
these things at a deeper level
okay
so all right so
so in this case if we look over here
we're taking a look at bubble sort you
have the configuration variable again
the way you actually would Define this
is extremely similar to the tags
um it just has a different variable name
and so then the idea
all right I want to set the
configuration variable
okay so same thing so things like git
config inside config are there in the
same way
all right
um
but once you do this uh the out
underlying display over here by
basically changing the configuration
variable uh the way it sort of displays
itself inside your notebook graph
notebook will change
all right so again this is mostly about
display Behavior user functionality uh
just to kind of give users a bit more
empowerment for the particular details
of how a particular class might sort of
display itself
so it's a way to basically
assign the behavior of certain types of
classes according to your own taste
yes yeah
yes yes maybe if you want to basically
change like output from like a numpy
array to a data frame or something
that's more user friendly or something
along those lines that's also the sort
of thing you might be able to change
with the configuration
all right
um so I know I think a few people
mentioned they've used sklearn before
other people haven't
um a little bit of background
information so a lot of times if you are
building out a machine learning uh you
know Library uh usually one of the most
important details you have to consider
is basically how your different classes
or estimators are actually composed
together inside of a larger pipeline
because most of the time they're going
to have to be a few different
pre-processing steps you might have to
use before you can actually Implement
some sort of ml algorithm or tool and so
a lot of times uh this is generally true
across different libraries just not
sklearn but some idea of a data
processing pipeline is usually pretty
important okay because it's actually
pretty unusual where your raw input data
is going to be perfectly suited for
whatever sort of analytical use case you
might have to use and so
in sklearn in SK time there are pretty
heavy uses of
of composite algorithms which actually
chain different processing steps
together so what we're going to do here
is just take a look at a very simple
example of a sample pipeline which is
basically going to take the shuffling
class
and then the bubble sorting class and
then chain them together inside one
function call okay again I think if
you've worked with SKT or SK time or SK
learn before something like this will
sort of maybe look like second nature to
you if you haven't really worked with
these before this might look the syntax
might be a little bit different but it's
definitely a design pattern which you
see quite a bit
so the idea then
what we're doing
is we're creating a meta class
that actually takes in
right both of our base algorithms here
right the shuffler and the Sorter and
then we're actually chaining them
together over here like this okay this
example
is a bit simplistic
but most of the time if you're actually
working with us I would say almost
anything okay in in real life it's very
very common there's some sort of data
processing step you're going to have to
chain together with whatever it is that
you want to do
all right and so in a way that's pretty
similar to how we actually defined
uh the actual base classes which
inherited right from the base permuter
uh here we're doing something
which essentially acts like a pipeline
and is actually able to chain together
the operations of both permuters
together so that way the operations are
performed successively
sure sure sure
Apartments
okay
yep let's I'm going to hope this thing
is going to work correctly
let's take a quick look
okay
real quickly friends
um yes yes this is in German so I can't
quite demonstrate it
hello okay yeah I see the idea then okay
thank you friends
um
yeah so if you're composing uh some sort
of pipeline that wants to chain together
multiple steps together
um so the functionality of things like
getting and setting parameters or
configurations or tags also exists at
The Meta level for the pipeline itself
versus the individual classes that we
defined before
all right
so if you want to build a machine
learning toolkit
probably the most universally used
method across most major tools is
something called fit all right which is
basically what you call when you
actually want to extract patterns from
your data uh in sklearn you basically
refer something that uses as the fit
method you refer to as an estimator
and so if you're building with SK bass
and you want to build an estimator again
which is something they want to use the
fit method
uh there's going to be a base estimator
class that you can go ahead and call on
okay
base estimator inherits from base
objects
so we're going to take a look at our
base permuter and then bubble sort class
this time inherited from base estimator
okay
quite a few of these details
are going to be about the same only
thing they were adding here
okay assort method which is maybe a bit
more semantic for what we're doing
and if we take a look over here at the
bubble sort class right which is also
inheriting from base permuter
okay inside the fit method
all right we're doing two separate items
okay
uh we're creating an attribute here
which is available after fitting okay so
if anyone's used SK learned before or SK
time uh fairly basically the standard
use pattern is that if you have some
kind of model artifact that's available
after done fitting it's usually made
available with a trailing underscore
afterwards and so if we can see that
over here
and then there's an awesome attribute uh
you know trailing underscore is fit is
now set to true
so
if you have
code that's similar to this built into
the fit method
should I run this
all right uh there's going to be an if
fitted attribute
which can return true or false
okay depending on whether or not you've
actually fit your dog with them
and then likewise after you're done
fitting a model
a lot of times you will care a lot about
what sorts of attributes are made
available afterwards so again if you're
using linear regression this could be
something like model coefficients or
intercept terms if you're using a
decision tree you know this could be
something like feature importances that
were determined afterwards
all right but if you actually build with
SK Bass uh there's gonna be the method
get fit params which is automatically
inherited from a base estimator
all right so last but not least
uh some of the built-in tooling uh for
for testing
all right so
this is an area that's maybe not the
most exciting thing to cover but is also
quite important because good test
coverage is is obviously really critical
to maintaining the health of your code
base
so what we're going to do now
is take a look at bubble sort
except this time we're going to go ahead
and then add in
a final class method here
all right called get test params
and the idea here is when you actually
build a class with SK based using a base
estimator you can Define what sorts of
parameters you actually want to use for
testing later on
it's the same thing
uh once you initialize a class actually
you don't have to initialize excuse me
because the class method
we had to figure out to run this
all right but the test parameters I will
meet available to you
and then also what you'll be able to do
as well
is create a test instance
that you can use for testing later on
and these will come pre-equipped
with the parameter values
that you set
here like that Okay so
we can make sure everyone gets this
notebook later on but the idea is uh
this is an introduction to the
collection of utilities that you have
available to you when you actually want
to go and start building with SK Bass
so thank you very much
and then I'm going to turn it back over
to Franz
and he is going to actually walk you
through how you might build an actual
tool using the SK bass tool
package
all right thank you very much
can you hear me
excellent
all right so in this final part of the
presentation
I will give a bit of a recipe on how you
would build a package with Escape base
which is the main use case right for
developer use of the package
and so what I'm trying to Showcase is
how to build an SQL learn like package
which makes use of Base classes
it's a strategy pattern and template
pattern for the extender tags and
configs retrieval I think where we've
already got a question so how do we set
up the retrieval functionality
heterogeneous meter estimators examples
would be Pipelines
and Composites that can take a varying
number of object or estimator components
and how to set up the test framework
last but not least
and what we're going to do
is follow a little bit of a recommended
recipe and it's my personal recommended
recipe you don't have to follow it but
but I have been
using it a couple times I think it's uh
what's Consolidated a little bit now the
first step comes from
General software design recommendations
so before you start designing before you
start abstracting it's good to have
actually implemented so at least thought
about but better actually implemented
some examples of the algorithms you want
to implement
and based on that the general rule is
well if you want to abstract think at
least about three substantially
different examples that cover your
space over which the design should vary
because that shows you okay do we need a
parameter here and there's always a
trade-off between under design being
group specific being too close to the
algorithm and over design covering too
many hypothetical cases that make your
design too complex and you don't really
need that complexity
so next two steps user contract and
extension contract what do I mean by
this the user contract would be the
unified interface that the user would
see so in scikitlelearn that would be
something like fit predict for
supervised tabular
estimators or fit transform for a
Transformers
for instance and including doc strings
what are the types what are the expected
input what is the expected output then
the extension contract right because
we're building a package that is psychic
learn like so it should be easily
possible to add more estimators of the
same kind so we need to write down if
you're an extender
where do you need to implement what do
you need to implement precisely and
these are the two two sides right the
extender side and the user side
that needs to be written down and can
already be a base class design
then you would start implementing using
the Base Class architecture with meter
classes is if applicable public
interface spoilerplate if any template
methods tax configs
and concrete classes based on that
now this might already be based on the
examples you have so you could start
with the examples you have Define the
interface and then try refactor your
examples subject possibly even through
functional equivalence tests to the
um abstract class interface of the of
the psychics learn like framework
then okay you might do this at the end
to draw up the very systematic
testing framework
or you can do this earlier to the degree
you are an adherent of of test driven
design
but we probably don't want to do that
earlier than number five because before
that you don't even know what your
interface is would be
retrieval will go about we will look
into that and also systematic testing
so
now the package we're going to implement
is not just psychic learn like
what I will try to show is how you would
based on Psychic base Implement
something that actually covers the same
use case as scikits learn and we're
going to focus on regressors and
Transformers
only just to show the entire pathway and
why did I choose this example well I
hope most of you are already familiar
with scikit-learn itself and the design
so the abstraction step from the
examples it will not be too unfamiliar
now you can of course try to do the same
thing with the example from part two as
an exercise if you want try to come up
with a nice design for sorting
algorithms for instance
so iteration zero
three example rule so you would need
three regressors three Transformers
three ways of composing
estimators right so in this repository
there is only one example but if you
would actually do this you would try to
write down three examples now the
different versions of the package so as
like in the cooking show right you start
cooking and then oh we've already
prepared it for you here here is the
cake which is almost done and well the
other thing is burning I'm not actually
going to try to implement this on the
Fly
um so here's the you can see them here
in the subfolders of Pi data underscore
Escape base and this is something that
you should also be able to run
the repository has its own requirements
file and and also leaves on on binder so
linear regression and this is not how
you have it in scikit learn right this
is just linear regression how it would
fit the model so it would return the
coefficients
and if you if you can use the pseudo
inverse then this is
ordinarily squares regression
with it's just a few lines and then we
return the coefficients this is no
intercept and just to make things very
simple play in a harmless data frame
used in the coefficients to predict
that's a simple matrix multiplication
okay that's linear regression
now the funny thing is I have the beta
here so that's I will see if I start
implementing other regressors I'm not
going to have the betas
the beta is actually a parameter so I
want this out of the predict there's no
there's no parameter in the fit but I
can also already think okay do I want an
intercept yes or no that might become a
parameter of the fit but I want to pull
this out into the object
and if I want to scale my data if
there's another example is a Transformer
and now maybe I've modeled it so I have
a parameter where I can select how I
want to scale it by the choice you can
make in psychics learn proper it's
implemented as two different
Transformers the min max and then the
standard normal scalar but you could
also think about it as a single thing
now this even is only a single function
it's not clearly separating A fitting
and a transformation step so this is
just to show how you would start so then
you would draw up more examples and you
would say oh there's actually things
that we're fitting here right these
these parameters here they're the
parameters we're fitting potentially so
I want to I don't want to compute the
minimum I don't want to compute the mean
or standard deviation on a test set
I want to compute it on the training set
and then apply it to the test set and so
on so these are the design
considerations by which you end up with
something similar to scikit-learn and
I'm showing this these thoughts to you
on in the example of scikit-learn
because you usually know psychic learn
you already know the um
the perfect answer in a sense to this
design questions and it's not always
perfect but it's pretty good in in most
of the places where design decisions
have been made and I want to show you
that if you build your own package then
these are design considerations that you
actually have to make from the very
start right why for instance this one
scaling function why would or should
separate this into a fit
and then transform it's not
obvious right why in linear regression
the beta it should not it should be a
parameter and not the input to the
predict that's not obvious you see that
if you have multiple pre-processing
steps that you look at together so
that's why this free example rule is
quite important
all right so let's move on from and this
phase by the way it can take a lot of
time good design can take a lot of
iterations a lot of
iterations upon in the idea space and on
the code base
first step
then think about the common Base Class
interface So based on the design you
would now come up with and I'm of course
dropping this from the heavens like
scikit-learn has dropped from the
heavens obviously
that you go with fit predict and fit
transform as we know it but now let's
suppose we have decided
on
based on the design that this is what we
want
so now we need to implement it as a base
class so
what we would do similar to how we seen
it in the second part so we need to
decide okay is it an object does it fit
do we need the is fitted thing here or
not if it's just an object like
splitter for instance or you could also
think about
um
a loss function that's an object it
doesn't get fitted if it's an estimator
if it gets fitted there's an ingestion
step there it's a base estimator
in this case the regressor is a base
estimator
and so we have seen the Sorting
algorithm you can consider both as an
object and an estimator depending on
what your conceptual model is the
regressor is an estimator
and so you now Define your interface and
what does interface definition mean
or do you actually write the abstract
doc string and as we see this is
slightly different from our psychic
learn actually does it right they're
both data frames
right and
so I do not want to go into any of the
details on what is better here because
I'm fully aware what they have been
heated discussions on the merits of
numpy and pandas and probably other
things as well and SCI kids learn I'm
just going to deviate slightly
from a certain established Norms here
just to show how things are different
so in and in predict of course if the
input here Y is a data frame then we
need also to return a data frame here
Transformer same thing right the design
sits here in the specification I say
okay here
what is written here to self is the
underscore parameters the state is not
mutated by the transform and the predict
method and it should also not have no
side effects I should have maybe written
that in the I should have maybe written
that in a doc string so this is the
first iteration right we're going to
have multiple iterations on this design
now we take our original code from
iteration zero and we can now implement
the linear regressor here
and okay I've added a shrinkage
parameter I'm not sure whether they've
actually implemented that and what you
would just have to add here
to the pseudo inverse and but what I've
also done oh I've added here some input
checks for good measure because you know
in the specification if you read the
specification it says oh The X
in
uh predict or transform it must have
the same columns as in in fit so we want
to check that and the in fit the length
of the X and the Y they must be the same
so we also want to check that
and the beta it's a parameter but we
have conceptualized the coefficients as
a fitted parameter so we want to so now
we need to write it to an attribute that
ends in an underscore
and this here this comes from the
scikit-based convention of the base
estimator if you use a base estimator
then the underscore is fitted parameter
needs to be set to true
by the fit method uh that's that's
convention house active base currently
works
in predict right we do some of the
checks and these checks are based on the
columns we've remembered from the X and
fit all right so far so good and
here transform
and this is fitting
a number of things and it's always
Computing these attributes which Iman
could also consider a questionable
Choice should we really always fit it or
not again just as an example we now have
one parameter which is a strategy
that we can choose here that's again in
deviation of psychic learn proper it
might actually be a worse Choice than
psychics learned proper because as soon
as you have a parameter that says which
algorithm do I use it hints at this is
not dry right you might want to split
this into two classes but again just for
the sake of just for the sake of example
again we do some checking here
we can also even do so we can even do
some checking in the in it and for
people familiar on the developer side
with scikit-learn this might be either
no go or a discouraged thing whereas in
and we do again some checks in fitting
and predicting all right so how is this
thing we can do it's not exactly
congruent which I could learn I want to
emphasize again I'm not making any
statements about what is better or not
design wise just showcasing
base object
that you can
make these choices
for instance this checking here in in it
yeah you can do that because in set
params
um
the in it is actually being called so it
happens in said params in it happens
inside set params now on the user side
this is how it will look like
it looks like
so we didn't Implement any get params
right if we
have pretty printing Now the default
here is HTML whereas if you I think if
you use scikit-learn proper it will be
we can it will be text you can switch it
around you can use the get fitted params
that will give you the beta the uh it
happens now to be I think it says Panda
series
predict produces a data frame
get params also works out of the box
yeah same with get fitted params
and so far so good now are we done well
you already seen here iteration two
there's some more things we might want
to do so we have only thought about the
user interface now we have not thought
about the person who wants to add a new
algorithm and let's think for a moment
about the person who wants to add the
new algorithm what does this person have
to do
well uh there's all this checking stuff
we now suddenly need to copy paste that
person so now you would have to write if
you would write an extension template
which I have also done so this is the
extender contract the extender contract
is an extension template which describes
how does the person who implements a new
algorithm what do they have to do
and to I think it's good practice just
to put here either in a separate piece
of documentation or you know if you
don't want to go that fancy you can just
put a fill in template which we also
have in SK time and it exists for
scikit-learn that's I think it's the
ancestor of these templates
it says what we have to add right you
have to write parameters to self you
have to call Super in it and then there
is the stuff which is always the same
right stuff is always the same
and then you insert the logic you write
the logic here and again here's stuff
which is always the same and insert all
the logic here
now from a design perspective this is
not very dry because you're telling your
extender your developer who writes a new
algorithm oh now just come on copy paste
all this stuff here and let's say you
want to change all this stuff here then
you do not just have to go to all the
places where all the stuff here
currently is because it has been copy
pasted all over the place
you also have to tell
all your extenders so potentially people
who have written their own estimators in
private code base as well from Tomorrow
there's going to be an additional check
here and we're no longer going to raise
this raise a value error but a type
error and you have to change all this in
your custom estimator so this is not
very nice towards the extender right the
the user doesn't see this but the
extender will curse you so and that
motivates the second iteration on the
extender interface so the input check
boilerplate is quite repetitive and so
it's not again it's not the only thing
you can do here or need to do even but
one way to simplify the extension
template is using the so-called template
pattern and the template pattern
um it's an object-oriented design
pattern the principle is
you isolate the pieces of code that are
always the same and from there you call
the variable part and the extender
implements only the variable part
and how this looks like
is
here in this iteration too
so we put all the in the Base Class the
base class is where we put the things
that are all the same right so we had
these checks here
stuff and stuff storing The Columns and
in predict checking the columns that
we've seen against the columns that we
now see
a new
and then we call in on the underscore
method so the templated
method
and that's what now the implementer
needs to add so the extension template
is now much friendlier and it has the
underscore here so the implementer might
wonder where is this being called from
but they don't have to copy paste all
this other stuff
and in psychic base this is also
supported by the interface design of of
the base object and the base estimator
simply by how we deal with things like
the fitted params or those or sorry or
the is fitted
or the estate handling say clone and
reset so reset for instance being called
from the set params other things we can
add also why not in the same iteration
let's add some tags so regressor type so
we can search our estimator base and
we add also a config so and the config
is enabled by now the template pattern
because now it's much easier to add
configs in this boilerplate layer
because let's say we want to convert the
output to pandas in the previous design
we would have had to copy paste this
convert output a million times if we had
a million estimators now we just write
it once
now in the boilerplate there that the
implementer never gets to see so here
we could have had say version
the 42 where we didn't have this didn't
have this output conversion and in
version 43 we add the config nothing
changes for the concrete estimators that
we have implemented because we add this
to the base class
and of course we can we can Factor this
out in more complex methods that we call
now from the boilerplate layer
in the
in in the Base Class yeah so the design
for the spoilerplate layer this is now
for
psychic time
and you have the public interface the
fit and you have the in-depth the
extender interface that's the underscore
fit both are friendly right they fit and
predict is friendly to the user the
underscore fit and underscore predict is
friendly to the implementer so the
learning curve for getting new
contributors to your packages is not as
steep because you don't have to know
about these special input checks and
conversions and all you have to write to
this you have to check that that all
sits in the
um boilerplate layer that only the if
most core of the developers need to know
about now of course there's there's pros
and cons doing it this way or doing
doing it that way
you're saying this is uh a design
decision you can make and it's for for
SK time I think it has been beneficial
because of the complexity of the time
series tasks you have to do a lot of
things there you have funny data
containers it's not it's not just a
plain numpy in in many cases
or or even pandas and even then you
might want to
go with the
so having even some functionality in
this spoilerplate layer like
iteration
over instances or dimensions
Broadcasting
anyway from the user perspective not
much has changed
still
looks and feels the same
you can inspect tags of course if you
want
all right iteration three so this is now
concrete estimators it's the Base Class
design itself
let's not talk about Composites
pipelines media estimators how do you
implement those and
so there are some classes in psychic
base which we haven't seen yet namely
the
base meta estimator
all right
and the base meter object they're very
similar to the meter estimator in
psychics learn if you if you know the
internals but exposed in a way or you
can use them as as templated components
for for your own machine learning
package
now the the estimated class works as
follows they have tags there's two tags
the named object parameters and fitted
named object parameters
they are these are strings they tell the
estimated where to look for a list of
name estimator
pairs like in the scikit to learn
pipeline so first show now before this
is going to be used before showing how
it's implemented because it might not be
entirely clear
what we want to implement here so we
want to implement a regressor pipeline
that
uh if given a list of either estimators
or a list of name estimated tuples will
produce the known behavior of a pipeline
with the get params and fit and so if we
fit the pipeline it has in this case
well we don't have a lot of
pre-processing steps so I'm simply
chaining two scalars here and the linear
regression
it has the get fitted Paramus behavior
and does the obvious thing so it first
applies the Transformers and then if it
predicts them so how do we Implement
that using psychic Bass
let's have a look at the new pipeline
module so nothing else changes except
the pipeline module in this third
iteration
yeah so oh I forgot to complete the dog
string
but this steps here it can be a list of
estimators or a list of name estimated
pairs or a combination thereof and what
this will do is we'll apply first the
Transformers so fit transform fit
transform and then the supervised
regressor
fit and fit and then transform it
applies it just to Transformer to
Transformers and then that's the predict
of the
and regressor
all right so this is just checking logic
don't worry about the checking logic
um
but what's important is that this base
meter estimator
it's used as
a
so it's used as a replacement base class
now
yeah so it sits it inherits from base
estimator and it also inherits internal
and circuit based from a meter estimator
mixing and this mixing provides a number
of utilities like the Checker so this
Checker check object
it clones the object and it coerces them
to Tuple estimate to name estimate a
tuple list
before that it could just have been an
estimated list
and they get names and objects it it's
basically just a fancy zip
on top of the Tuple estimated list but
it also occurs if it needs to so then
you can Implement your custom logic on
top of that
to get you
uh the index where the regressor sits
and otherwise raise an error in
underscore fit again so we have dealt
with all the checking and conversion all
we do is implement the logic this is the
logic of pipeline
basically and we call not the underscore
fit we call the fit
and in predict
we it's it's just sequential application
really
now
this is the pipeline and not the other
thing we need to do we look in the base
class so now we have the base meter
estimator we're inheriting this from
Psychic base meter estimator and also
now
we would notice we would need to put
these tags both in the base estimator
and the base meter estimator
but we can just get them from a common
mix in because tag and config
inheritance is by element so return time
and we can just put them in and don't
worry about these attributes being
overwritten by for instance this one
here right so this is not the estimator
this attribute
it does not if you use get tags to
access the tags it does not
override these tags as we have
previously seen and that's why we can
Factor it out into whoops
this one here
okay
so now we have implemented our meter
estimator and again it didn't take long
if you know how to use a scikit base you
can take this as a template if you want
all right so now the lookup and search
functionality that we want also want to
add to our package that's iteration
number four
and the way to do this is using all
objects in Escape base that is a utility
which basically does all the crawling
and filtering for you
and
you can look at the dog string of it of
course all you need to do is interface
it and set some of the parameters so the
the important bits are pointing to the
right directory excluding directories
for instance very extension templates it
maybe where your test fixtures sit and
if you want also to be able to search by
a string for regressor you need to map
these onto a registry but this is not
necessary you can also use classes or
you can use tags for subsetting so if
you type your regressor your estimated
type already sits in a tag you don't
actually need to write a registry so it
works out of the box
the way it will work is right you have
this magic function all estimators and
this gets you all the estimators from so
anything that inherits from base object
in your package you can use it to filter
by tag so you can say I only want the
regressors in my package
yeah or you can also do this by
providing the class directly
here
now internally I have said this is so
the function is called all objects
because not all the objects are
estimators
but of course you might want to use it
only for estimators there's just a a
small distinction just need to be
careful about the difference between
objects and estimators
and now this talk string is just
mirroring the dog strings most the copy
paste of the dog string of
psychic base
all objects
all right so what's what estimator types
do you want
an argument to filter by tags an
argument to exclude from estimators do
you want to to return as a
tuples or data frame do you also want to
have some tags listed in the return
table which might be useful if you're
trying to tabulate here
and all it does really is interfacingly
all objects
if you want to have some syntactic sugar
so if you type regressor as a string it
knows okay I have to inherit from bass
regressor but you don't need to do that
if your estimator types it's in a tag
the important bit here is pointed to the
package root directory
so I have just sneakily pointed it into
a relative path it might depending on
your setup might you might have to
fiddle around with this argument here
and of course we want to ignore the
tests and the extension templates
because the extension templates they're
not
a complete right so if you try even try
to import that so if you ignore the
modules it doesn't even try to import it
so if you have broken code in there like
you might have an extension template
it's not trying to import it and the
utility is not going to throw an
exception
all right
last but not least testing just quickly
brush over it so you might do this
earlier or not the only thing this
iteration adds is
um
a test class which is seen by pi test so
your Pi test CI runs or local Pi test
runs will find the class and what this
class does it tests the base object
interface contract so for instance are
all the parameters being written to self
in it things like that do you call Super
init
or do you move into the base object in
it this is all tested by tester objects
you can also write your own tests and
you check estimator utility
right so you can call the test class
directly you get some basic testing
functionality for the base object
interface and here we also have defined
our own test for the linear regression
class
and the example here and the tests it
shows
how to
set this up
so you need to configure
the package where the package sits
objects you want to exclude so again
extension templates if you want your
tags to be checked for validity and this
is this is something you need to add
here
the test all objects you can just
inherit this from test all objects and
if you want to add your own tests there
are certain
arguments that the test class already
provides
for your tests so object instance it's
so you might have been wondering okay
what is this create test instances and
names in part two what is this good for
well this class the base fixture
generator it Loops through all the test
instances and exposes them as object
instance so this test is executed for
all test instances and there is more
refined functionality where for instance
you can generate data based on
properties of the object object instance
is not shown in this tutorial but if you
want to see some examples you can look
into the SK time
test framework it's it's explained there
and of course if you want this to be
tested only for rig resource then
there is the object type filter variable
so all the config variables for the
testing framework you can also look at
them in the by looking at the test all
objects in the SK based repository it's
not as well documented as one might like
but coming back to what I said at the
very start contributions are very much
appreciated right this is a SK time SK
based they're both openly governed
openly LED projects which invite
contributions by everyone psychic base
hopefully will be useful to you as a
reusable workbench for creating psychic
learn like scikit-learn psychic time
compatible libraries
we've gone through how to create your
own package with public interface
extension templates how to use attack
config and testing system most of it
works out of the box it needs a little
bit of adaptation hopefully
taking a lot of the time or if from the
case the alternative where you would
build this all manually
all right I've already set this SK time
is openly governed if you would like to
contribute please let me know if you
want to get started with contributions
do open source in general
or SK time
an orange Escape base
feel free to find me here at the
conference I'm still here until then
Friday at the very end
the regular Community collaborations for
SK time and Escape base on Fridays you
just go on the GitHub go on the Discord
join send me or any of the other
developers please post in a Channel or
send a private message at Friday's 4 pm
UTC which would work for most time zones
there's an open
developer and contributor meetup on the
Discord we're going to have mentoring
and internships again this summer
there is opportunities for some paid
summer internship slots as well there's
unpaid mentoring so the
um the proposition there is you invest
some time for contributing and in turn
you're mentored by an experienced
developer if you want to learn more
about those look on at the SK time slash
mentoring repository there's always also
a list of the current opportunities for
more structured
a mentored contributions or internships
there an onboarding session for SK time
contributions will be held in June
that's coincident with the start of the
summer internship cohort and there's
going to be a developer Sprint location
TVD possibly virtual in July 2023.
so more than happy if you'd like to join
if you also would like to
get our help in building your own
package we're here you can contact us or
just go on Discord and let us know all
right any
questions in the remaining half minutes
two
um
so this is this is really formative uh
it's good about it so I'm not sure if
you record it but do you want to
maybe this is
a dress so it's recorded also Fair
um so this is really informative and uh
about you know how to build this sort of
tree structure with the inheritance and
yada yada I'm
the thing that I'm sort of missing here
is uh what are we getting by using SK
bass that we're not getting by using
like just the mixins that are provided
in the SK learn base
um like because we have you know like
the regressor mix-ins and stuff like
that that add that sort of functionality
oh sure so the meter level so if you use
the I think so of course base estimator
from Psychic learning is also something
you can use
obviously but that gets you all all the
fit stuff and it gets you idiosyncrasies
around the tag and the config system so
I think the config is
uh quite tied to the specific estimator
types which are in psychic learn now I
have been in the past actually that's
how it started for psychic time we just
used base estimator we just inherited
everything from base estimator and then
we started bumping into all these idios
increases specifics of
sciq learn where it didn't quite work as
we wanted yeah the tags were working in
a funny way and we wanted to Define our
own tags and we wanted to control
Behavior so we started increasingly
replacing functionality in the psychic
learn base estimator
by
more abstract functionality right and
then in the process we abstracted away
most or like let's say 60 of the psychic
learn-based estimated and we thought
well if we now copy the rest then we
actually have a quite nice templating
templating framework
and to so also people from the SK time
Community started using it then for
their work projects where for instance
you have to
Define a specific kind of algorithm for
which there isn't a toolbox out there
and it's really sector specific so okay
you can take base estimated but then you
will run into the same side issues again
so I'm not saying phase estimator is
unusable no it's actually excellent you
you can just import base estimator and
you have pretty printing you have the
composition already but but some of the
things you've mentioned my iron tag
system fitted parameters so for instance
in Time series you want to inspect the
fitted parameters you have parameter
estimation and you want to plug them in
say in in other estimators if you want
to do say Auto arima or Auto ETS
and or automatic seasonality detection
and a seasonality you want to plug in
into another estimator well either you
need to have used the same same
attribute or done some attribute magic
or you have something like get fitted
params which makes it easier
if I could follow that up
um any other questions Maybe
all right of course
okay so I'm am I correct in inferring
from your answer that there there are
conflicts name conflicts between SK bass
and the mix-ins from sklearn.base and
you could potentially use them both but
then you have to check your like you
have to check the order of your
inherence because it affects the mro
yeah I thought that was a simple one
so SK Bays is not inheriting from
Psychic learn right
yeah but it is fully compatible
create a class that that inherits from
both SK bass and scikit-learn.base right
but then which one wins when uh uh if
I'm calling super depends on how I have
them yeah but wait if so if you inherit
first from Psychic base base estimate it
overrides everything
and so I could learn so it's a superset
of functionality
the the public interface is a superset
of functionality as far as I know
so if you override
scikit-learn based estimator with
psychic bass based estimate you
basically get psychic based base
estimator
if you do it the other way around you
break the functionality that is
additional in scikit-based based
estimator
not all of it
what if I just really like your Tech
my
news base object
you you override base estimated from
cycle and space object other questions
I'm out of time right
and I'm going to get thrown out and it
seems like people
okay
[Applause]
for coming